[Music]
rankings
when was the last time i did a good
opening gag does anyone remember cuz
i don't okay in
a recognition of the first trailer
coming out for the batman
uh which may even eventually get
finished shooting at some point once uh
once its leads
get over the plague uh i
thought you know what i think it's
finally time for me to pull the trigger
on something i've been thinking about it
for a while which is to rank
all the batman movies now as soon as i
say that i need to qualify it i am only
going to be ranking
theatrically released films
uh and to be clear a theatrical release
uh it needs a proper wide screen release
they needed to have actually intended to
people go
hey let's go to the movie theater and
see x so
i know for things like killing joke and
a few other things they had like
limited one or two night fathom events
sponsored things yeah no that doesn't
count
so none of that is included also not any
movie in which batman appears
counts so uh you know he technically
appeared in suicide squad
that's not a batman movie he needs to be
one of
the major characters not necessarily the
major character but he needs to be one
of the people who is moving the plot
forward for me to count it as a batman
movie so by the measures that i have put
forward i've got 12 movies to rank
let's do it starting with naturally
number 12.
batman and robin yeah let's just get the
obvious one
out of the way right away the thing is
i've tried to be kinder to this
with time and i've tried to give it a
fair shake you know being older and
getting over
you know the whole oh it's not dark it's
not
it's not a real movie nonsense kind of
stuff that was cluttering up my
headspace back when the thing came out
originally
but even if i account for the fact that
it is deliberately trying to be campy
it's still painful it still doesn't work
it still doesn't pull it off i get what
it's trying to do
but what it's trying to do is not fun
it's not enjoyable it still
doesn't work so even by the measure of
adjusting myself to try and get on its
wavelength i still
can't stand this movie
number 11 batman v
superman dawn of justice i'm sorry
it's just a mess now that being said
batman himself is actually one of the
highlights of the movie
the performance overall feels a heck of
a lot more
thought out than a lot of what was done
with superman or lex luthor
and also he's the highlight in terms of
the action scenes
so i would say batman is one of the
stronger elements
of a film that is it's a mess
i'm not gonna sit here and crap all over
the thing and say it has no redeeming
features
it does it has some cool moments it has
some cool beats but
it's nonsense
i'm sorry it just is it barely makes any
sense it over complicates everything it
does
to the point where even if i can make
sense of it i still don't understand why
you would do it the way that this movie
did it
number 10
the dark knight rises this is one that
has been steadily dropping in my
estimation basically since
two weeks after it came out it's
just kind of a damp squib
of a movie it just doesn't land
especially
coming off the film that preceded it and
granted there's a lot that it couldn't
help
i'm pretty sure they would have liked to
have had heath ledger back
to be in this thing but that wasn't
going to happen but this take on bain is
not particularly interesting the twist
at the end just doesn't land
at all the whole thing that they do with
batman in terms of
having him retire but then he's not
retired and now he's
back but but so gotham like got on top
of everything
except it's somehow still a powder cake
like
it doesn't feel thought out nearly on
the level that the other nolan movies do
and it it's just i came away going i
guess that was pretty good but
every day that i've thought about it
since then it just keeps dropping
number nine
this one might get me in trouble i'm not
sure actually this one and the next one
might get me in trouble
uh batman returns here's the thing
i i don't think batman returns is a bad
movie
it's actually depending on what measure
you're going to use
it's pretty good it's a pretty good tim
burton movie it's
not a good batman movie and i'm not even
talking about the basics of like
oh it messed with the origins of you
know
where penguin came from and how catwoman
like i don't care about the messing with
the lore or the origins
the characters are unrecognizable in
behavior in the way that they are at
all like even bane in the previous one i
could still see the thread
from where he came from in the comics
but like here
you just picked two actors from the time
made one look like a monster and slapped
another one in a fetish outfit that said
michelle pfeiffer's catwoman
i'm not gonna lie that was kind of a
seminal part of my uh
my uh young years then
uh but ultimately this thing just
doesn't
hold together
number eight justice league
this is the other one that's going to
get me in trouble no i'm not saying
justice league is good
and yes i am talking about the
theatrical release because
nobody's seen the snyder cut yet aside
from snyder
in theory um well except even he hasn't
because he needs
more money to finish the dang thing but
anyways
i had fun with this movie now i will
readily grant
a pretty big part of that was lowered
expectations it's probably the same
basis on which i actually kind of had
fun
watching the rise of skywalker doesn't
mean that was a good movie
doesn't mean justice league is a good
movie but i did just have more fun with
it
i enjoyed the lighter vibe i really
thought that henry cavill was
great at superman and this when he sure
as heck didn't click with me and the
other ones
he is actually really really good
playing a superman who smiles
crazy notion he's a really good fit for
that i'm not saying you can't do
superman the way that they
did him in man of steel and batman v
superman but i am
saying that you know henry cavill
was not as good as that version as he
was in this now i'm talking about
superman there's supposed to be a list
of batman
batman himself in this he's not the
highlight the way he was
in batman v superman so this is a case
where
his actual contribution not what i'd
consider one of the
stronger elements of the film but
he's in it i have fun with it in a way
that i can't
actually concretely defend but i just
kind of shrug and go i thought it was
okay
number seven
batman forever this is where we start
getting into the movies that i will
actually legitimately go to bat for oh
god
that was an unintended pun but batman
forever
the first jewel shoe marker movie i
think is pretty good
it is it's very visually stylized but in
a way that has not gone completely off
the rails
the way batman and robin later would i
honestly think that jim carrey is a good
pick
for the riddler yes he's doing jim
carrey and kind of his stock
uh character but he works
he works for a kind of bonkers slightly
off his rocker manic
version of the riddler it's a good fit
the main thing dragging this down though
is
well if i'm being honest val kilmer is
pretty wooden so that doesn't help but
honestly
my big complaints in this are uh two
face and tommy lee jones and i normally
love tommy lee jones
but he clearly didn't get this character
nor did the writers nor did
the director they just put him in well
basically because they were running out
of other big name
villains to put in so they said oh we'll
do two-face
and we'll have him flip a coin but yep
but is he actually going to adhere to
the coin no he'll keep flipping it till
he gets the results he wants that's not
two-face
yeah that that drags it down a bit i
won't defend two-face
i will defend the rest of this movie
though
number six
batman begins christopher nolan came out
swinging
in this one not gonna lie there
is just a lot to love the amount of
attention paid to
what would go into batman just
taking on the mantle what what did he go
through what did he put himself through
to get from being bruce wayne hurt
injured angry young man to batman
hurt angry injured young man with a
bucket on his head
but it's it's a really cool journey and
it it was a nice
dive into it and it made that journey
interesting so that you weren't sitting
there the whole time going
when's he gonna be batman when's he
gonna be batman and say you're going ooh
this is really cool it's gonna be even
cooler when i when i get to see him as
batman
so that worked really well um i really
do enjoy
uh this take on scarecrow i think he's
really solid
there are a number of things bringing it
down though the fight scenes honestly
are one of them the fight scenes are
very poorly shot they're too tight
they're too cut heavy you can't tell
what the heck is going on but for the
most part this
does pull together really well there's
also a little bit of non-linear
storytelling and i'm not sure why other
than
nolan kind of just tends to do that
a lot of the time and by this point it
was just kind of a signature thing that
he did
but it is it is just a good
film looking at the origins of batman
number five
another possibly controversial one we'll
find out
batman the one based off the 1966
tv show i mean i won't lie this is
a lot of this is nostalgia i grew up
watching this movie i didn't really
watch
the show it was in reruns when i was a
kid but i didn't really watch it but
i did watch this and i re-watched it i
watched it a lot
and it's just so fun this is what batman
and robin
wanted and completely failed
to be because yes it's campy yes it's
over the top but
everybody who's in it has a sincerity
they deliver jokes but they aren't
talking like
like there's gonna be a rim shot right
after they speak
it's just got this perfect blend of
earnestness and ridiculousness and i'm
sorry
all these performances are great
you have a great catwoman a great
penguin a
great joker i would argue the best
riddler
there have been some great riddlers i
love the riddler from gotham
but frank gorshan as the riddler mwah
beautiful and adam west just owns
as batman look some days you just can't
get rid of a bomb
but this movie's not a bomb this movie
rocks
number four
batman from 1989.
again this is probably a in a
large part nostalgia i will own up to
that it's my list i can use whatever
criteria i want
i probably can't completely defend
this versus say batman begins as being a
better movie if someone
really wanted to back me against the
wall but i enjoy this
more i grew up on this movie
michael keaton is my favorite
live-action batman
i think that jack nicholson was a
terrific version for
mobster joker he's great he owns that
part
really really well there is just a
great layering of a certain amount of
camp i would say a largely brought on by
nicholson himself
and then tim burton's dark aesthetic
where it's not drowning out the fun the
way that it did in batman returns
here it is both fun and dark it's a
wonderful balance that
tim burton wasn't able to find again and
arguably the franchise itself never
quite
hit again in the exact same way
number three lego batman
i'm serious this is not a joke
lego batman gets who
batman is gets what his damage is
what is baggages it's presenting it
humorously
yes it's making fun of him yes but the
people who wrote and directed this
they understand who batman is
because the people who are best equipped
to make fun of something
are the people who love it and know it
inside and out and they totally do win
this
and it is making fun of batman's whole
self-serious thing especially the way
batman had been for the last few decades
in
films up to that point it's so wonderful
to see this light
bouncy energetic robin thrust onto him
and just sort of crowbar his way into
his life and batman's like
no i'm not gonna smile you can't make me
kind of attitude
it's so terrific and at the same time
honestly
quite poignant the way he pushes people
away the way he
won't let himself care that's actually
mine for some legitimately good stuff at
the tail end
the only reason that's this doesn't go
higher if i'm being honest is
i don't super love this joker he's
written well and he's utilized pretty
well but i
i don't particularly love the vocal
performance zach
galifianakis was fine he wasn't great
but he was fine
but there's it's just so fun and funny
and quotable
oh wow is this movie ever quotable from
uh killer crock going i did something to
bane getting decked by batman for no
reason going
necessary oh it's so much fun
number two
the dark knight let's not kid ourselves
heath ledger owns this movie
he just completely rules the roost
the entire run of this thing there's a
reason the movie opens
on him he is the driving force behind
the story
behind the film it's just
hypnotic and mesmerizing
to watch him just dance nonsensically
around
all these people who are trying to
figure him out and think sensibly and
he's just
i'm not he's having none of that he
clearly has a plan
but does it follow any logic that any
other person who makes this kind of plan
whatever hap probably not
it's so fantastic and as much as you
know
heath ledger goes to the top of the list
for the reasons this is great
bunch of other great stuff too gordon's
great
harvey dents great and alfred's great
even rachel dawes despite the fact that
yet she gets
damseled and then fridged i i do
think that there is still a good
chemistry and a good use of the
character while she is
in it the main thing that ke
that kept this from the number one spot
honestly
was the two-face plot
gets wrapped up kind of hastily at the
tail end
in many ways the joker hanging upside
down
is the relief of the cl is the release
following the climax of the film the
climax was was
building up to the boat explosion and
then you know the joker
hanging upside down monologuing at
batman that's our
okay cool down from that but then we've
got this other thing that keeps going
and it doesn't it it loses momentum a
bit
and it i think the movie knows that and
that's why it rushes
through the the two-faced stuff at the
tail end which is
pretty much the only thing keeping it
from the number one spot but if you know
your batman movies you already know what
the number one is
number one is batman mask of the
phantasm
which at this point it's not even that
controversial to call it the best batman
film because people who are
open to animation they know
that this is the best batman film i've
had nitpicks
at least about everything else on this
list i have
no notes no complaints
nothing i'd change nothing i'd tweak
nothing i would expand it is
perfectly tailored for what it wants to
do
from the new characters introduced to
the elements of batman's backstory
and the flashbacks we get in us to learn
like what he went through not in terms
of training the way batman begins but
what he went through
emotionally to become batman
to really resonate with this idea of he
has assumed since his parents died that
he would never
be happy and the idea that he might be
happy is actually kind of traumatic for
him
and the first putting on of the mask is
not triumphant
it's a tragedy because this is not a
happy life for him
this is an animated film and it knows
batman to the core and it's got a
stellar voice cast
across the board they're all amazing and
of course mark hamill's joker
makes an appearance in this doesn't even
show up through until
halfway in but he's well integrated into
the story and it's a
brilliant vocal performance and it's all
just perfect
i would not change a lick of this thing
that's why it gets my number one spot
for the best
batman movie where will the batman land
on this i don't know
find out when i eventually see it but
what is your ranking if you don't feel
like doing all 12 or if you haven't seen
some of them
what's your top five top three
how wrong am i whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it all the usual stuff
to do you know what it is like share
subscribe i have a patreon
naturally of course and that helps keep
the lights on and keeps this entire
operation
up and running because what's paying my
bills right now
so that helps but all the other stuff
does as well there's links to things
down in the description including a
kickstarter for my novel
so check all those things out or don't
if you don't feel like it that's all
right too
because end of the day you're the
council i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you